I don't know like if I ever get elected
into any house or Congress or anything
like that I there's got to be a way to
make these false allegations illegal
like like there have like there has to
be something listen
most men have a friend that has had a
friend if not them that's been falsely
accused most men know of a man who they
have a child with a lovely young lady
the child the the child's mother can
utilize some false accusation to remove
that child from that man's life I
got a story on my channel me being
falsely accused of some we all all
of us we all see we won't want to talk
about that
holding them accountable all of a sudden
we want to talk about that